-What a great audience!
-They love you.
-Thank you.
-Come on.
-And I love you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's all right!
We have to --
[ Laughs ]
We have to talk to her! I know!
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Oh, my --
I'm not gonna get time
to talk to you!
-I know!
I'm not gonna get any time
to talk to you!
-Yeah.
Well, you better hush, then.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
'Cause we gotta talk.
-We have to talk.
All right.
So, we have a lot to discuss.
First of all, congratulations.
You were just inducted into
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm a rock star now.
That's what they say.
-I mean --
-That was such an honor.
You know?
I'm making an album, too,
'cause I have to live up
to all that hype.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-At first, you were nervous.
You were like,
"I don't know, guys.
What do you mean?
Rock 'n' roll? I don't know."
-Well, honestly, I was sincere.
I did not mean to start
any kind of controversy.
But when they said
they wanted to put me
in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame,
I always thought that was
for people that spent
their whole life working to be
in rock 'n' roll.
And, you know, you don't see
Led Zeppelin
in the Country Music
Hall of Fame.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought --
Although they could.
But anyway, I found out
it was more than that.
So when I realized what it was,
I said,
"If they put me in anyway,
I would certainly
accept it gracefully,"
which I did.
Even wrote a song about it
to kind of
tell the story about it.
-Yeah.
The Zach Brown Band.
That was great.
-I know.
But anyway, I'm very honored
and very proud.
It did --
I'm good about timing,
so I'd always thought
I might want to do a rock record
'cause my husband
is a rock 'n' roll freak.
-Yeah.
-So anyway, I thought,
"Well, if I'm ever gonna do it,
now's the time."
-So you're doing
a rock 'n' roll record?
-I am. It's gonna come out
next fall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
And you know what
I'm calling it?
-What's that?
-"Rock Star" is the name of it.
-Yeah. Are you gonna have any
good duets or cameos on there?
-Well, actually, I am going
to have a some cameo people.
-People are watching
our show tonight.
-I've written a few originals.
-Okay, good.
And a couple originals.
-And we're gonna have a lot of
great, iconic songs,
like "Purple Rain"
and "Can't Get No Satisfaction."
-Oh, my God!
That's what I'm talking about.
-"Stairway to Heaven"
and "Free Bird."
I'm even did "Free Bird."
-Oh, my gosh!
I cannot wait for this.
-But I'm gonna have
a few guest artists.
-Okay, good.
-But anyway...
-I'm looking forward to that.
Come back for that.
Please do.
-All right.
Well, I love singing with you.
I might have to --
I might have to get you in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm probably gonna faint again.
I want to talk about
our adventures.
The other thing
I want to talk about, too, is,
you and Miley are teaming up.
You're co-hosting
New Year's Eve in Miami.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We are.
In Miami, with Miley,
on New Year's Eve.
Can you imagine that?
-I'm so excited.
-We're gonna have great fun.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
Do you like doing live?
Do you get nervous or no?
-Oh, no.
And Miley and I are so great --
She loves you, too, by the way.
-Oh, no.
I say "too" because I love you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Don't everybody?
-You're my favorite.
-Anyhow, we're gonna do
a great thing.
I'm sure we'll ad-lib
a whole lot of things,
and we're gonna
do some songs together
and a few rock things
with some of the artists
she's gonna have there.
Lord knows what could happen
with Miley and me.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lord knows.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love her.
Oh, you and me are the best!
-How cute is this?
-I know.
-I mean, that is the best thing
I've ever --
I just thought it was so cute.
I had the greatest time
doing this.
-Yeah, this was great.
I think that's a great song.
And I told him years ago,
I asked him to sing with me
on another song, and he said,
"Oh, I don't really
think of myself
as a serious singer.
I just like to have fun."
I said,
"I think you're a great singer."
So, anyway, we recorded,
last year, Mariah's song,
or year before last.
But then this year,
he sent me this song and said,
"Would you do a duet with me?"
And I said, "Well, absolutely."
And so we did it.
-We did it.
-We did it in the show, too.
-So I thought, I go,
"Let's do a song
that's almost a little bit
too early for Christmas."
-Yeah, I love that.
-And we'll release it
in October.
And so --
[ Laughter ]
So, we put it out
right before Halloween,
and it went to number one
on the Apple iTunes charts.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-We have a number-one hit song!
-I know!
I'm so excited.
-Releasing a holiday song
in October works. Who knew?
-But that's a great song,
by the way.
-No, you made it into a song.
I gave you nothing,
and you're like,
"Oh, watch me do this."
-Oh, sure. Yeah.
I did my part.
-Can we talk about the special?
Because I had the greatest time
hanging out.
I got to hang out with Dolly
for a full...two days?
-Yeah, full two days.
-It was great.
"Dolly Parton's
Mountain Magic Christmas."
It airs tomorrow night on NBC,
8:00.
Everyone, set your DVRs.
Tape this thing.
Watch this thing.
Have a party.
It's awesome.
I'm in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
You did great, too.
And we loved having you.
-We did well, right?
Willie Nelson's in it.
You and Willie.
-Miley.
-Miley Cyrus is in it.
Jimmie Allen's in it.
-Jimmie Allen.
-It's a big giant special.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-Jimmie Allen, Jimmy Fallon.
It rhymes.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and Zach Williams,
who I had a Grammy Award song,
"There was Jesus," one of my
favorite songs on the album.
-Your sisters, too.
-And my sisters, and my nieces.
My sisters Cassie and Rachel
are there.
I couldn't round
the rest of them up.
I got a bunch of them.
But anyway...
We did a whole family thing,
and it was just wonderful.
-So, I flew to Tennessee
to meet you.
-Whoo!
-There you go.
We allow four people
from Tennessee
every night to come in
to the show.
There they are,
sitting right up there.
-Oh, that's sweet.
-Yeah, it's nice of us.
-Hey, there!
-So, I was so excited
because we were filming
in Dollywood.
-Yeah.
-At Dollywood!
Which I was blown away!
-I know.
Didn't it make a great --
We got everything.
There's, like, a movie set.
Anything that you could need.
It's a paradise.
I'm very proud of it.
-So I land in Tennessee,
and I wanted to just get there
so I can drive around.
I wanted to go to Sevierville,
where you grew up
and see all your --
You know, just get a little
Dolly love and spread it around.
I got to pose next
to your statue, by the way.
-Oh, yeah, I heard you did that.
-Yeah, I saw your statue
right before you, yeah.
I saw you.
-In my bare feet.
-In your bare feet.
-That's the only time
you'll ever catch me
out of my high heels.
-That's right.
-I've got bare feet.
-That's your bare feet.
That's the only time.
So, here's what happened.
I didn't have a driver.
I didn't set up a car.
So, I just called an Uber,
right?
So I get in the --
I just call an Uber.
-You call it a Goober
if you were up there.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah!
I got a Goober.
I called --
I went on the Goober app.
So, I go on Uber,
and this guy shows up.
His name is Chad, so shout-out
to Chad if he's watching.
And I get in the car,
and he goes, "Oh, wow."
He goes, "I just got --
before I start the car,
I'm just freaking out right now.
I didn't know it was you,
and I've never met a celebrity.
This is just bizarre for me,
so just give me a second."
I go, "Yeah, no problem, Chad.
Take as much time as you want."
[ Laughter ]
So, he starts the car.
He was really nice.
So, we're driving through,
he's talking about you,
and we're talking about
how great you are
and we love you.
And I'm there,
and I just landed,
you must have heard
that I landed,
so you called me.
-Oh, yeah,
to see if you was here.
-You call me, and you go,
"Jimmy, how you doing?
You landed in Tennessee?"
And all I see is Chad going...
[ Laughter ]
And I go, "Chad!
Stay on the road, buddy!"
He's like -- He's freaking out.
He goes, "Was that
Dolly Parton on the phone?"
He's like, "This is
the greatest drive of my life!"
And it was so fun.
-And you had barbecue.
-Yeah, I went and had barbecue,
and then we rehearsed.
We danced together.
-Everybody loved you.
And when you left --
I mean, you just brought --
It was just like somebody
flipped the lights off
in Booger Town.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Like, everybody --
There's a place up there called
Booger Town, right in that area.
So, but, anyway, everybody said,
"He is the nicest guy."
And I said, "You know,
you don't know the half of it."
But everybody said,
"Well, did you tell him
our famous story
about our bear?"
And I said, "No, I never
got a chance to tell that."
Do you have time for it
on the show?
-Yeah, please.
-Well, this is a true story.
Up in Pigeon Forge
is where we were.
And I know you asked me
why they call it Pigeon Forge,
and I told it's because
that's where pigeons forge.
But anyway...
-Thank you for that.
-There's the Pigeon River,
and I guess the pigeons --
-Foot in mouth.
There you go, yeah, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-But seriously,
in Pigeon Forge, many years ago,
back when I was a kid,
they had a bear in a cage.
You know, we're famous
for the bears in the Smokies.
And they had a bear
in a big cage up there.
And people would stop
at this market,
and they would buy Cokes for
this bear that was in the cage.
And tourists would take pictures
'cause Gatlinburg,
that whole area.
For years, you know,
they would put Cokes and peanuts
in the Coca-Cola cans
or whatever the --
Bottled Cokes were then.
So, anyway, this bear was just
getting bigger and bigger.
But they were doing that,
and they were just selling
all kinds of stuff
at this market.
And this poor bear
was just drinking them all.
And one day, some redneck put --
[ Laughter ]
No, seriously.
They put gasoline in a Coke can.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Can you believe
how bad people are?
And the poor thing
just went crazy.
And it broke out of the pen,
and it started towards
Sevierville
because Pigeon Forge is about
eight miles from Sevierville.
And it just ran
all the way down there,
you know, and it was
just going down there.
And all of a sudden,
it just fell over.
-Oh.
-I know.
-Dead?
-No.
It was out of gas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-I love you!
[ Applause continues ]
I love you!
I love you so much!
You are the greatest!
Ah, she got me!
Hook, line, and sinker!
-Yeah.
-It is so fun to hang out.
"Dolly Parton's
Mountain Magic Christmas."
The special is about
bringing that magic back.
What are we missing?
The love, the coziness
of the Smoky Mountains
and all the fun.
It is so fun.
There's music, there's dancing.
-Yeah, a lot of comedy.
A lot of kids stuff.
So, something for everybody,
so be sure to watch it.
Lot of meaningful things.
-I loved --
I'll never forget hanging out
with you as long as I live.
I had so much fun with you.
And we danced from --
I'm not kidding,
and I wish it was different,
but we danced
from 10:00 to 3:00.
Almost 9:00 to 5:00.
-It wore me out.
[ Laughter ]
-10:00 a.m. --
10:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m.
we hung out and danced.
-You were so fun.
Though, I have
to thank you, though.
You were so generous.
-You're acting is good.
My acting is terrible.
You can act.
You can do everything.
-But you can dance.
See, I'm not a dancer.
I was like,
"Sing the song and drag Dolly."
I know that's how you felt.
-No way.
We had the best time.
-But we did dance.
And we did have fun.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
-Can we show a little of it?
-Yeah.
Here's Dolly and I...
-Okay.
-...in "Dolly Parton's
Mountain Magic Christmas."
Take a look!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ It's almost too early
for Christmas ♪
-♪ Too soon
to be singing this song ♪
-♪ There's still
Halloween decorations ♪
-♪ And haters will say
that it's wrong ♪
-♪ Let's turn on the lights
for Mariah ♪
-♪ To Rudolph
to shine up his nose ♪
-♪ It's almost too early
for Christmas ♪
♪ But why don't
we see how it goes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww!
-Come on, now!
Come on!
That's how you do it!
-Yeah, we do!
-Dolly Parton!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dolly Parton's
Mountain Magic Christmas"
airs tomorrow night at 8:00 p.m.
right here on NBC!
We're talking more with Dolly
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.